both of us have passions 4:54 wanting to
make change change for good
Megan Marco is serving the community
with her mom by her side for the first
time since the Royal Wedding the Duchess
of Sussex appeared in public with her
mother Dora Raglan at Kensington Palace
on Thursday for the launch of her
cookbook together our community cookbook
this is more than a cookbook and what I
mean by that is the power of food is
more than just the meal itself it is the
story behind it the 37 year old royal
was seen helping several of the chef's
prepare dishes for the event and joined
the women of the hub community kitchen
to make green rice for the celebration
while it's uncommon for family members
to attend official royal engagements
Doria fit right in looking lovely in a
tan sweater and pants with a pulled back
ponytail she proudly watched her
daughter as she greeted guests on palace
grounds megan wore a blue pea coat black
turtleneck and matching skirt for the
occasion while her husband Prince Harry
looked dapper in a gray suit jacket and
navy slacks on a personal note I'm
especially grateful because this is my
first project so I appreciate your
support in the vision that I had for
this and seeing it come to fruition the
Duchess addressed the crowd at the event
in a speech and thanked the women who
shared their 50 recipes in the cookbook
we are going to inspire people globally
by sharing your stories and your recipes
it's so impactful you can see just in a
few days alone and the books not even
out yet what you've been able to do
that's a testament to what this means to
people and I'm so proud of you
[Music]
[Applause]